tu as envie de regarder quoi
j'en ai un peu ma claque des faits
divers et si on regardait
elle a carrément la même coiffure que
toi
[Musique]
la première question que n'importe
quelle plateforme va vous poser c'est
c'est quoi la croche
la première étape c'est d'admettre que
vous ne contrôlez pas la situation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je rêve ou c'est sales bingo
il est comment un café dégueulasse je
lui ai pas dit ça comme ça c'est une des
adaptations de la vie de Joan tous les
abonnés de streamberry peuvent le voir
ce type
sur ça que vous faites votre
documentaire les détails sont tellement
horribles que ça en devient captivant
ouais j'adore
[Musique]
et il est seul
on a l'impression tous les deux que tu
devrais faire une pause je crois que
j'aimerais vraiment beaucoup
il s'est fait virer du tournage il y a
deux semaines Nick propose 30 000
dollars pour une photo d'elle
et la moitié de ces connards se
flingrais si on les prenait pas en photo
mademoiselle
[Musique]
si ça
vous dit complètement
il faut que vous
devez rester humble face à la réalité
les technologies d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
pour garder pas Joan et horrible non
mais c'est sur ma liste